[Applause] It's
not like before, the great
difference between Mexican soccer and
statuette soccer,
the second edition of the welcome course
of the law is approaching,
where teams from the Liga
MX face the most popular
of the most
popular people.  Don't think that Las Vegas only
has almost no good food, good fun,
that there is also good football, that's
how it was on August 1st when
the Mexican and American fans
said they were present for the first gold cup
in the city of sin, that's the  same
adrenaline that will be felt on
September 22 when sanders will
face the lion in the house of the
wailers of candles
in tiger transactions
[Applause]
in 2019
cruz azul became champion after
defeating tigers 2 to 1 in a  game
where the spirits were a bit
upset
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Cruz Azul was the first champion of this
tournament in this edition León will
face Sanders if Aarón
beat San  cough 1 to 0 while in the
other semifinal león beat pumas 2 to
0 a team from the mls a team from the
mx league who will win we will know
next wednesday here behind my back
inside the stadium the legend reported
for them to give a  spanish natalia
lanzelotti